what color underwear are you wearing do
you actually want to know
sure it's a orange thong that's Dragon
Ball Z underwear Beyond these dude I'm
not kidding myself wear them every day
that print is crazy yeah I know I don't
[__] around like I rock the ones that
have dinosaurs on them those look like
you [__] around
I want to fancy you in public yeah
nice spaceships guy when you pants
someone it's supposed to be you're
supposed to get them like naked right no
that's it'll be even funnier
dinosaurs out there just stand in front
of the Mongolian beef [__]
they're like you got dinosaur print
that's weird they just move your food
across the grill into the trash Burger
King's that way let me get yourself some
chicken fingers chicken tenders or